مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
اختطاف مواطن سعودي على طريق مطار بيروت
وزير الداخليه اللبناني يحذر من العواقب
على علاقات لبنان العربيه
ويتوعد خاطفه بعقاب قاسم
على وقع تجدد الاشتباكات بالخرطوم انتهاء
هدنه الاسبوع الواحد بالسودان ومفاوضات في
جده للضغط باتجاه التمديد
سماء تشهد اعنف معركه بين باتريوت الغرب
وصواريخ ومسيرات روسيا واوكرانيا تتحدث عن
منطقه منزوعه السلاح كشط للسلام
حرائق ضخمه وغير مسبوقه تتسبب
بتفتك بكندا والسلطات تعلن حاله الطوارئ
في مناطق متضرره
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الداخليه اللبنانيه بسام مولوي
بان الاجهزه الامنيه اللبنانيه برمتها
متاهبه لمتابعه قضيه المواطن السعودي
المختطف في بيروت واضاف وزير الداخليه
اللبناني ان الوزاره تتابع مع السفير
السعودي في لبنان وليد البخاري ادق
التفاصيل هذا وشدد على ان عقاب خاطفيه
المواطن السعودي سيكون قاسيا مؤكدا بان
اختطافه يمس بعلاقه لبنان باشقائه
اذا مشاهدينا قبل ان انتقل الى بيروت
ساشير الى هذه العواجل التي وردت الان حول
عمليه خطف المواطن السعودي في بيروت بحسب
اخر العواجي المصادر اللبنانيه تقول بان
الاجهزه الامنيه مستنفره ودون تحديد طبعا
مكان المختطف السعودي حتى الان وايضا
وسائل الاعلام اللبنانيه تقول بان المواطن
السعودي المختطف كان يقيم في بلده عرمون
اللبنانيه
وبانه شوهد للمره الاخيره قرب وسط بيروت
وايضا مصادر لبنانيه تتحدث بان خاطفون
مواطن السعودي طلبوا بسديه ماليه وبان
الصعود المختطف يعمل لصالح الخطوط الجويه
السعوديه وطبعا كان هناك تصريح لوزير
الداخليه اللبناني قال فيه بان عقاب
خاطفين المواطن السعودي سيكون قاسي جدا
وبان اختطاف المواطن السعودي يمس بعلاقه
لبنان مع اشقائه العرب وايضا
ان الوزاره تتابع هذا الموضوع وهذه القضيه
مع السفير السعودي في بيروت طبعا سيكون
معنا وزير الداخليه بعد قليل قبل ذلك
سانتقل الى مراسل العربيه محمود شكر من
بيروت محمود ما هي اخر المعطيات التي ممكن
ان توفينا بها حتى الساعه نعم ساذهب معك
سريعا الى التعليمات التي تصدرها السفاره
السعوديه في بيروت منذ بعض الوقت علمنا من
مصادر المقربه من السفاره الى ان تعانيم
داخليه خرجت الى الموظفين في السفاره وفي
القنصليه وفي الخطوط الجويه السعوديه بان
يلتزموا منازلهم ومكاسبهم وان لا يكون
هنالك خروج لهم في داخل العاصمه او في
المناطق الاخرى هذه المساله كما اشرت
اليها ارخص بظلالها الامنيه السلبيه على
الواقع اللبناني برمته وعلى الواقع ايضا
هنالك بيان سيخرج من السفاره السعوديه
يتحدث عن انها تلقت نبا فقدان الاتصال مع
الموظف في الخطوط الجويه السعوديه وهي
تتابع مع خطين متوازيين ان كان قياده
الجيش اللبناني وايضا مع وزير الداخليه
وشعبه المعلومات بالاضافه ايضا علمنا لانه
هنالك اتصالات مكثفه داخل العاصمه بيروت
من قبل السفرات والسفراء العرب وتحديدا
الدول الخليج والعربيه باتجاه السفاره
السعوديه للوقوف على اخر المعطيات في هذه
المساله والتي ايضا اعتبرتها مصادر انها
تاتي في توقيت دقيق وحساس وخاصه في ظل هذا
الانفتاح العربي الذي ارخى منذ حوالي
الاصبعين على الواقع اللبناني برمته في
المعطيات الامنيه وايضا التي حصلنا عليها
الى انها
الموكب الذي كان يقتاد المخطوف لان
السيارتين مع سياره ثالثه ولكن في كلا
المواقع الثلاثه لم يظهر اثر لهذه
السيارات الا فقط بعمليه الفتح الهواء
هاتف له وهنا توضع عده احتمالات في اي
منطقه هم ذهبوا اليها وايضا بطبيعه الحال
المصادر الامنيه تتحدث الى ان هذه طريقه
في عمليه التعميم عن التمويه عن مكان
الخاطف الذي يتمكن الخاطفون به كما اشرنا
كان في الحزميه عند المدخل الشرقي للعاصمه
بيروت ثم بعد ذلك خرج في قلب الضاحيه
الجنوبيه ثم بعد ذلك خرج في منطقه زهر
البيضاء هذه مساله عمليه التنقل من منطقه
الى اخرى على كل حال
محمود
سيكون معنا بعد قليل وزير الداخليه للحديث
عن تفاصيل عمليه الخطف وبالتالي اذا امكن
اعاده ايجاز اخر نقطه شوهد فيها المواطن
السعودي اين هل من معلومات كيف تم يعني
استدراجه من هي المجموعه هل يعرف هؤلاء
الاشخاص ام لا معطيات حتى الساعه حول هذه
التفاصيل
نعم اخر نقطه هي كانت في احد المطاعم في
بيروت وايضا عند الواجهه البحريه هو ايضا
جاءت مجموعه بلباس عسكري وخرج عند الباب
مع هذه المجموعه التي دعت الى انها بصفه
امنيه ثم بعد ذلك
اقتدته
لتغيب الادله الحسيه للموكب المثلاث
سيارات عند طريق المطار هذه اول مسار
المساله الثانيه الى ان هاتفه فتح على
ثلاثه مراحل بثلاثه اماكن مختلفه بثلاثه
ازمنه
متقطعه اهم هي عصر
هذا بهاتف بصوته برساله صوتيه عبر
الواتساب الى موظف في الخطوط الجويه
السعوديه يطالب بها المخصوص لمديره ان
يساعده بتامين مبلغ 400 الف دولار امريكي
محمود
يعني علاوه على ذلك وزاره الداخليه وسلطات
اللبنانيه يعني بحاله استنفار قصوى
والمعطيات التي خرجت بالساعات الماضيه بان
هاتف المخطوف يعني الرسائل ترسل من منطقه
الضاحيه الجنوبيه هل تم حاسم هذا الموضوع
ام لا
هذا الموضوع بالنقاط الثلاثه بالنقط حسم
عند الاجهزه الامنيه باول نقطه كما اشرت
معك في الحازميه في الضاحيه في ظهر البيدق
الان
اخر نقطه كانت اين هل هو اين هل بقي في
الضاحيه ام هم توجهوا به الى منطقه البقاع
وخاصه عندما نعلم الى ان هاتفه ايضا فتح
الاتصال به من عند طريقه ظهر البيدر هل ان
الخاطفين ذهبوا به الى منطقه البقاع ام
اقاموا بهذه عمليه التمويه وكانوا ينتقدون
به من منطقه الى اخرى
من
جهه فالسعوديه السعوديه السعوديه من جهه
الثانيه هي تطلب ان نتكسب او هي تتكتم
بطبيعه الحال عن كل ما هو ذات بعد امني في
هذه المساله لانها تضع الاهتمام الاساسي
هي ليست بعمليه القطف بقدر ما هي بسلامه
المخطوط وان يؤدي الامر الى تحريره خاصه
في الساعات القادمه لربما بعد هذا الضغط
الذي هو جزء منه سياسي على اعلى المستويات
في لبنان او ايضا الضغط الامني الذي تقوم
به لان كل الاجهزه الامنيه في لبنان من
الاستخبارات العسكريه الى شعبات المعلومات
الى الامن العام الى الدوله هم يعملون في
هذا الاطار محمود يعني ايضا باطار
التحقيقات اذا كان هناك معطيات من يعرف
المواطن السعودي ان كان اصدقائه او ربما
يعني الجيران في الحي او في المبنى هل
تحدثوا عن اي معطيات اضافيه عن اي شيء
يعني او اي نوع من الخوف او التهديدات كان
يتعرض لها
بالايام والاسابيع الماضيه
سؤال برمته حملناه الى المصادر كان الجواب
ان هذه البعض الاسئله الدقيقه الاجوبه
الدقيقه عن كيف عمليه محمود محمود ابقى
معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك بعد قليل مشاهدينا
ينضم الينا من بيروت وزير الداخليه
والبلديات بسام المولوي اهلا وسهلا بكم
معالي الوزير سابدا من المعطيات الاخيره
حول عمليه الخطف اين هو المواطن السعودي
الان ما المعطيات والتفاصيل حول هذه
العمليه خصوصا اننا يعني نتابع الكثير من
من التفاصيل التي ليست محسومه انما كانت
رسميه ام لا
مساء الخير
القوه الامنيه
ولا سيما شعبه المعلومات في قوى الامن
الداخلي وكافه القوه الامنيه تتابع منذ
البارحه
هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع مهم هذا الموضوع
دقيق جدا هذا الموضوع تتابعه القوى
الامنيه بكل حرفيه ومهنيه
ويجري التواصل بطبيعه الحال مع السفير
السعودي مع معالي السفير وليد البخاري
لاجل متابعه الموضوع ولاجل اطلاعه على ما
يلزم من تفاصيل وعلى ما
تحصل عليه القوه الامنيه نحن علينا متابعه
الموضوع هذا موضوع لا نقبل به هذا موضوع
يمس بعلاقه لبنان
بالدول العربيه الشقيقه ونسيمه بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ان امن وامان كافه
المقيمين على اراضي اللبنانيه ولا سيما
المواطنين العرب والمواطنين من من مواطني
دول الخليج العربي ومواطنين المملكه
العربيه
هم اشقاء وان امنهم وامانهم مهم جدا
للبنان و لعلاقته ولعلاقه لبنان بهذه
الدول الشقيقه اننا نتابع الموضوع منذ
البارحه
اننا تابعنا ونتابع الموضوع طوال الليل
الماضي وطوال اليوم
اننا نتابع حركه الاتصالات نتابع حركه
كاميرا
في كاميرات المراقبه الممتده في بيروت وفي
محيطها واكثر ابعد من ذلك على الاراضي
اللبنانيه
يعني الزملاء في بيروت بان تم رصد هاتف
المختطف بثلاث نقاط تم ارسال منها رسائل
بالساعات الماضيه من اي منطقه خطف هل فعلا
الخاطفين كانوا بذي عسكري واوهموه بانهم
من القوى الامنيه
طالما انت تقولين ان المعلومات لديك او
لدى
الاعلام تقول بانه تم رصد
مكالمات او رسائل هاتفيه من اكثر من منطقه
هذا يعني ان
هاتف المواطن السعودي يتنقل بين اكثر من
منطقه في بيروت وهذا يدل على
عمل معين لدى الفاعلين وهذا يستوجب على
القوى الامنيه اللبنانيه ان تكون على قدر
كبير من الحيطه ومن الحذر وان تتعامل مع
الموضوع بدقه بالغه
ينبغي لسلامه التحقيق
ولسريه التحقيق الواجبه للوصول الى نتيجه
ولسلامه المواطن السعودي طبعا وهي الاهم
ان نلتزم بحد معين من سريه التحقيق
لجلاء كافه الملابسات طالما كما تقولين ان
الفاعلين يتنقلون بالهاتف المنطقه الى
اخرى ضمن بيروت او يمكن بيروت فهذا
الموضوع
ضمن بيروت ومحيط بيروت هل فعلا يعني وصل
الى ظهر البيدر هل ممكن الحديث عن انه
اصبح خارج بيروت
لا لا لا نحن لا يمكن ان نؤكد مثل هذه
المعلومه انما كاميرات المراقبه
تفيدنا بكل التفاصيل من كل مكان في لبنان
حتى
انت تقولين انها تم رصد شيء معين في في
كاميرا في ظهر البيدر هذا دليل على ان
القوى الامنيه تتابع الموضوع بشكل جيد اما
ما قلتيه عن ان الخاطفين يرتدون الزير
العسكري فهذه معلومه
لا نستطيع ان نؤكدها بل هي لم ترد الينا
بهذه الصوره
واننا نتابع الموضوع بسريه وبدقه وبحرفيه
وبمهنيه وطبعا من واجبنا طالما الموضوع
يتعلق بمواطن سعودي ان نحيط السفير
السعودي وان نعمل معا لسلامه المواطن
السعودي
ولم تهتم به السفاره السعوديه
ومعالي السفير وليد البخاري شخصيا بما
يتعلق بسلامه المواطن السعودي هذا الموضوع
هو من واجبنا هذا الموضوع نعم
حسب يعني معطياتنا ام اعلم بانك لا تريد
ان تدخل بالتفاصيل كثيرا ولكن نحن مضطرين
ان ناخذ يعني على الاقل شيء من كل الاخبار
التي تخرج لمعرفه دقه هذه الاخبار مصادرنا
في بيروت تقول بان سياره المواطن السعودي
وجدت في البقاع وبالتالي بان المخطوف تم
نقله من بيروت الى البقاع ومن هنا تم رصد
الهاتف باخر يعني باخر مره تم فتحه فيها
عن بظهر البيدر هل فعلا وجدت السياره في
البقاع
يعني مع التحفظ على المعلومات على انه يجب
ان نحفظ السريه لك السياره لم لم يعثر على
السياره في البقاع ولم يرصد الهاتف في
منطقه ظهر البيدر هذا غير صحيح هذا غير
صحيح
حتى الان
اما موضوع الفديه الماليه
فبحسب تداول ما تداولتم في وسائل الاعلام
وعلى محطتكم تحديدا ان هذا الموضوع لا
نستطيع ان ننفيه وانما طالما ان المواطن
السعودي له اقرباء وله اصدقاء في السعوديه
وهو مواطن سعودي فمن الطبيعي ان انه في
عند
وجود مثل هذه الاتصالات ان يتم ابلاغ على
السفاره السعوديه
بالامر هذا موضوع
طبيعي ان تعلم السفاره السعوديه
بموضوع طلب اي مبلغ مالي من ذوي
المواطن السعودي الذي
بالساعات الماضيه وبالتالي الهدف من عمليه
الاختطاف هو هو عمليه يعني ابتزاز ماليه
اذا صح التعبير نعم ام لا
نحن نحن نتابع الموضوع
وسيتضح قريبا وجليا الهدف من العمليه
والمهم بالنسبه الينا كشف كافه كافه
الخيوط
والعثور على المواطن السعودي سليما باذن
الله حتى الساعه اليوم يمكن القول بان
يعني المواطن السعودي بصحه جيده هو بخير
هو بمكان يعني بحسب كل الحركه التي
رصدتموها بالساعات الماضيه وهل فعلا تمرضت
هاتفه بالضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
تم رصد الهاتف بامكنه مختلفه ضمن بيروت
وضواحيها وليس في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
لم يتم رصد حركه هاتف في الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت
انما ما يرصد من الهاتف
وفي عده مناطق والتنقل في عده مناطق يدل
على ان المواطن السعودي مازال بخير
تاثير ان تتمكن القوى الامنيه من ان تجده
قريبا
نهار
الساعه
ان كان الجيران او ان كان الاصدقاء
بالمنطقه التي يقيم فيها الى ماذا خلصت
حتى الساعه وهل يعني كان ابلغ قبل فتره عن
اي تحرك او اي احد يعني
حاول ان يستدرجه الى مكان ما
الاختفاء حصل فجر الاحد واننا نتابع
التحقيقات منذ ذلك الحين ان جيرانه في
مكان اقامته في عرمون لم يدلوا باي
معلومات تتعلق بانه قد تعرض لاي تهديد نحن
نتابع الموضوع بدقه نحن
على اتصال دائم مع سفاره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولا سيما مع سعاده السفير مع علي
السفير وليد البخاري
ان الفاعل سوف يلقى جزاءه لن نترك مثل هذه
الجريمه تمر لن نترك موضوع اختفاء مواطن
سعودي على اراضي اللبنانيه يمر دون حساب
الحساب يجب ان يكون جديا وقاسيا ورادعا
ير الوزير يعني
تحدث بان هذه العمليه ليست بالتفصيل
وبانها تاتي في خضام يعني سياق بشع جدا
وهي تؤثر بطريقه كبيره وتاثير كبير على
العلاقات اللبنانيه السعوديه واللبنانيه
العربيه ماذا ستقومون من تدابير بهذا
الاطار خصوصا وان هذه العمليه ممكن ان
تؤثر ايضا على البحث بالمستقبل عن عمليه
عوده السياح
والزوار العرب الى بيروت
الموضوع يتعلق بالامن والامان في لبنان
الموضوع يتجاوز مساله السياحه ويتجاوز
مساله الاصطياف الى الاهتمام بالامن
والامان للبنانيين ولكل المقيمين على
الاراضي اللبنانيه ولا سيما منهم الاشقاء
العرب وبالاخص الاشقاء السعوديين عمل
القوه الامنيه الجيد والدؤوب لكشف تفاصيل
لكشف التفاصيل
ومصداقيتنا
لدى الشعب اللبناني ولد الاشقاء العرب ولا
سيما الاشقاء السعوديين تؤكد بان مثل هذه
الحادثه لا يمكن ان تؤثر على علاقه لبنان
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه وعلى اهتمام
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بلبنان وبشؤون
لبنان فالمملكه العربيه السعوديه لم تترك
لبنان ولن تتركه ونحن لم ننقطع ولم تنقطع
علاقتنا بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه من هنا
ومن
منطلق واجباتنا وواجبنا
نهتم بالموضوع ونتابع الموضوع وسنصل الى
نتيجه
ولن نترك هذا هذه الحادثه تمر مرورا سريعا
او تمر دون عقاب مهما كان الامر شكرا لك
وزير الداخليه اللبناني بسام المولوي على
وجودك معنا
[موسيقى]
تنتهي هدنه الايام السبعه في السودان
الهدنه التي وقعت في جده في العشرين من
مايو الحالي بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع وسط تواصل المحادثات التي تقودها
الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه بين الطرفين
بهدف الدفع نحو تمديدها وهو ما قد يتاكد
خلال وقت قصير من الان لكن وفي هذه
الاثناء تشهد اجزاء من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم سلسله اشتباكات عنيفه فيما افاد
مراسل العربيه بسماع دويا انفجارات اثناء
تحليق الطيران الحربي في ام درمان
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الامنيه للبلد عمل التردي في
القطاع
الصياد طلعت من الخدمه نحن في منطقه هي في
مرمى النيران
كلها يعني غيار جروح عنده علاج عنده متوفر
في البيت او زايد يوديه لناس الطوارئ احنا
هنا في الراشدين شمال بنحتاج لكل الادويه
بنحتاج للاطباء محتاجين لاي زوجات انه
يساعدنا
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من جده لنا يعقوب
مديره مكتب العربيه في السودان لن يعني
خرق الهدنه هو الشيء المعلن والمعروف حتى
الساعه تمديد الهدنه التي هي اصلا مخروقه
ولم تساهم بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه ما
تفاصيلها وكيف يمكن ان يلتزم بها الطرفان
من جديد
مساء الخير عليك ليان هذه هي المره
الثالثه يفترض ان يكون هناك تمديد لهذه
الهدنه كانت هناك هدنه في الحادي عشر من
مايو ثم بعد ذلك في العشرين من مايو والان
قد يكون هناك تمديد لهذه الهدنه هذه الهدى
بصوره عامه تتركز على وقف اطلاق النار وضع
الترتيبات الانسانيه بصوره مسناسبه بمعنى
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه وعدم اعتراض
عمال الاغاثه والان هي تناقش كثير من
التفاصيل التي تم اختراقها وتم خرقها عفوا
في الاتفاق الموقع في جده في العشرين من
مايو والذي استمر لمده اسبوع الوساطه
السعوديه الامريكيه شرحت في بيان مفصل
كثير من هذه الاختراقات التي حدثت والتي
وقعت لذلك الان هذا التمديد بلا شك سيناقش
هذه النقاط اولا سيركز على تفعيل اليه
لعدم تكرار هذه الفروقات والمتمثله مثلا
وجود طائرات مسيره وهو خرق للهدنه
واستمرار احتلال المنازل من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع واستمرار عمليات السلب
والنهب والتي حددت في البيان لذلك هذه
الهدنه تاتي لحمايه هذه الترتيبات
الانسانيه خاصه ان هناك مساعدات انسانيه
ادخلت خلال الايام الماضيه
ومساعدات طبيه وصلت لبعض المستشفيات رغم
سوء الحال لذلك الوساطه حريصه على
استمرارها لتتمكن المساعدات الانسانيه من
الدخول وكذلك لوقف عمليات اطلاق النار
التي قلت مقارنه بالاسابيع الماضيه لنا
باي توقيت من المتوقع ان تدخل هذه الهدنه
حيز التنفيذ
والاعلان عنها يعني البيان الجديد باي
ساعه من المرتقب ان يتم الاعلان عنه
[موسيقى]
طبعا العيال حتى اللحظه لا يوجد تاكيد
رسمي اصلا ولكن المصادر تحدثت انه من
المتوقع ان يتم تبديد هذه الهدنه التي
تنتهي في
العاشره و45 دقيقه بتوقيت الخرطوم بعد ذلك
يعني هذا هو الموعد المحدد لنهايه الهدنه
التي استمرت لي اسبوع وكانت بعد 48 ساعه
من توقيع هذا الاتفاق في العشرين من مايو
ولكن من المتوقع خلال مساء هذا اليوم ان
يكون هناك تمديد لهذه الهدنه البعض يتوقع
خمسه ايام البعض يتوقع اسبوع ولكن كافه
المؤشرات سواء كان من الوساطه من الدعم
السريع من الجيش يتحدثون عن ضروره التمديد
ولكن هناك شروط طبعا موضوعه اي ان الجيش
يصر بصوره واضحه على ضروره بان تستمر هذه
الهدنه على ضروره التزام الطرف الاخر
بخروجه من المستشفيات ومن منازل المواطنين
على الطرف الاخر الدعم السريع يضع ايضا
شروط بعدم قصفه وقصف الاماكن التي يتواجد
فيها بالطائرات وهو امر ايضا يعتبره خرق
للهدنه لذلك هذه التفاصيل قد تتضح في
البيان الذي سيصدر في مساحه اليوم في
انتظار صدور البيان شكرا لكننا يعقوب
مديره مكتب العربيه في السودان حدثنا من
جده
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
كسب المئده يا اصدقائي
في تركيا اردوغان يواجه شارعا منقسما غداه
فوزه والقوميه ما هذا الطريقه لولايه
جديده وهي الاخيره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حرب جديد من نوع اخر
تشهدها سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
صواريخ كنجال ومسيرات شاهد الايرانيه
تطلقها موسكو وتترقبها للتصدي لمنظومه
باتريوت الامريكيه الغربيه التي وصلت
لحمايه العاصمه كياف التي اعلنت التصدي
لصواريخ روسيه في سمائها مؤكده انها اسقطت
معظم الصواريخ والمسيرات بينما اعلنت دفاع
الروسيه انها اصابت كل اهدافها اما سياسيا
فشرطت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه منطقه حدوديه
منزوعه السلاح تمتد ل120 كيلومتر في اي
تسويه مع روسيا بدوره اكد مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني يوريساك للعربيه بان
الهجوم المضاد الذي تتعرض له بلاده لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده بل بسلسله
عمليات شعريه
اما فيما يخص هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا
غير صحيح لان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لا
يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه واحده في ساعه معينه
ثم نراها على شاشه التلفزيون هذه الهجمات
المضاده هي سلسله من العمليات الصغيره
والكبيره والبعض منها جاريه منذ عده
اسابيع
مخاوف روسيه كبيره من فقدان السيطره على
الاجواء الاوكرانيه في ظل استمرار الدعم
الغربي لاكياس للسيما بمنظومات الدفاع
الجويه وايضا المقاتلات الحربيه لذلك لا
شيء يشغل بال موسكو وقواتها سوى البحث عن
مواقع انتشار منظومه الامريكيه في
اوكرانيا خصوصا بضواحي اكياس كون هذه
المنظومه الجويه الامريكيه تتركز لحمايه
العاصمه ما تطلب الدفع والزج بصواريخ
كنجال الروسيه المتطوره في تحقيق ما تسعى
اليه موسكو وهو تدمير بطاريات باتريات
اينما وجدت في اوكرانيا ليبقى الجو تحت
سيطرتها وفقا طبعا لما فسره مسؤول عسكري
غربيون لكن مشاهدينا استهداف هذه المنظومه
ليس بالامر السهل طبعا على القوات الروسيه
التي لجات في محاوله لتجنيد جواسيس داخل
مركز القياده الج للقوات الاوكرانيه
لتدمير هذه
الدفاعات وفقا طبعا لتقارير استخباراتيه
غربيه واوكرانيه هنا الدفاع الروسيه
بدورها اكدت انها مصره على تدمير كل سلاح
يمد فيه الغرب اوكرانيا مشيره طبعا الى ان
عمليه تدمير الباتريوت لا تستغرق وقتا
طويلا لان سرعه صواريخ كنجال تسمح لها
بالوصول الى منشات عسكريه ومنظومات دفاعيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بسرعه الضوء وفي
غضون دقائق وفقا للوصف الروسي لكن يبدو ان
المشكله الاكبر تتمثل بتحديد مواقع هذه
البطاريات لتدميرها وضربها بهذه الصواريخ
معنا من موسكو مشاهدينا عبر سكايب بافل
فيلجنهاور المحلل العسكري استاذ بابل يعني
موضوع استهداف باتريوت والاسلحه الغربيه
وتحديدا الاستهدافات الاخيره وطبعا
بالماضي تاتي في صلب ما دائما يعرف بان
التفوق العسكري الروسي على الارض تقريبا
تقريبا يعني هزت صورته بعد اكثر من سنه
على الحرب ما زالت الصوره العسكريه التي
لا طالما بنت موسكو كل صيتا عليها هي
الصوره الباقيه اتحدثون عن التفوق بنوعيه
الاسلحه وخصوصا الجويه منها هل تدمير هذه
الانظمه الدفاعيه والاسلحه والطائرات ياتي
تحسبا لهز هذه الصوره بالمستقبل القريب
[موسيقى]
المواجهه روسيا بشكل عديده فما خصوص
سمعتها
القوه الجويه
لم تتمكن من
السيطره على الاجواء
اوكرانيا ولكن الان
هنالك تعزيز
القدرات الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني من قبل
الاسلحه الغربيه ويبدو انها كافيه
التاثير عبر الصواريخها المستقبل في
الدفاع الجوي فروسيا تحاول استنزافا
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه فحصلت هجمتان خلال
يوم واحد ضد ذكيه
والصواريخ
والمنظومات الغربيه الاخرى الحديثه دافعت
عنها
وهنا يكون عامل هامه جدا
عامل نفسي لاستنزاف هذه المنظومات
بالانجليزيه لزياده الابعاد عليها من خلال
التعدد مع الصواريخ المواجهه ضدها
وبالتالي هزيمتها ولهذا السبب اعتقد هذا
هو سبب الهجمات اليوم وفي وضحي النهار
لانهم يستخدمون
الصواريخ اسكندر البالستيه الجويه والتي
لديها اجهزه توجيه بصريه وتعمل عندما تكون
السماء زرقاء وفي وضع النهار وهكذا كان هو
الحال اليوم في كييف
موضوع يعني نشر الدفاعات الجويه الامريكيه
تحديدا والطائرات هي كانت جزء من يعني
الخطاب السياسي لفوتين حتى بمرحله ما قبل
الحرب اليوم مع دخولها الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هل ممكن ان تعطي ذريعه للجانب
الروسي الى الذهاب ابعد بنوعيه الاسلحه
التي يستخدمها على الارض
روسيا تستخدمه كل شيء تقريبا كل ما لديها
في ترسالاتها ما عدا الاسلحه النوويه
بالتاكيد التي لم تستخدم ابدا ولكن اي نوع
وكل الانواع الاخرى من الاسلحه استخدمت
بين ايدي روسيا
وكلها اخرجت من المخازن
سواء منظومه السوفيتيه
ولكنها
لم تجري امر كما توقعها الجيش الروسي
يتوقع ان تكون هناك هجمات اضافيه ضدك مره
اخرى من اجل زياده الاعباء
على مضروبات الدفاع الجوي خلال التعدد
الاهداف
وبالتالي فعليهم استخدام
عدم كبير جدا من الصواريخ الغربيه المكلفه
بالتالي فان
المنظمات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه والصواريخ
سوف تقل بشكل كبير شكرا لك
ابل المحلل العسكري حدثنا من موس
كو اشارت مجله نيوزويك نقل رئيس بيلاروسيا
الكسندر لوكاشنكو الى المستشفى المركزي في
موسكو بعد لقائه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين واضافت نقلا عن زعيم المعارضه
البيلاروسيه بان الرئيس البيلاروسي المقرب
من بوتين في حاله حرجه وتم ارسال افضل
المتخصصين لعلاجه طبعا بحسب نيو سويك
[موسيقى]
في تركيا انتهت قبل قليل عمليات فرز
الاصوات بنسبه 100% طبعا والتي اسفرت عن
فوز الرئيس اردوغان بولايه جديده بنسبه
51.91% مقابل
48.9% لمنافسه كمال كليتشار اوغلو اذا
وخلال عقدين من اعتلاء السلطه في تركيا
كيف بدا اردوغان سياسته مطلع الالفيه وكيف
تحولت هذه السياسه بعد انقلاب الخامس عشر
من تموز عام 2016 اليوم مع بدايه ولايه
جديده هل يعتبر اردوغان وفقا لسياساتها هل
يعتبر وفقا لسياساته اسلاميا ام قوميا ام
اتاتوركا فلنتابع التفاصيل
بين هذه المشاهد وتلك اكثر من عقدين من
الزمن وكثير من التحولات لسياسه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحولات يقول
كثيرون ان هذه الصور كانت الفيصله فيها
على تركيا وعلى محيطها
فمنذ المحاوله الانقلابيه في صيف 2016 سلك
الرجل طريق الانفتاح ليس على الداخل فحسب
بل الخارج ايضا
منذ بدايه العقد الاخير فتح الرجل ابواب
بلده للجماعه وقياداتها لا سيما بعد
فرارهم من مصر وسوريا غير انه عاد وقرر
نجم الجماعه ومنصاتها الاعلاميه عقب مد يد
التقارب مع مصر وحتى مع النظام السوري
بشكل ما
خلال الاعوام الماضيه شهدت العلاقات
التركيه توترا واصل الى ما يشبه القطيعه
مع دول خليجيه لكن اردوغان عاد لاصلاح
العلاقات ماخوذا بالمصلحه التركيه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه لم يخفي اردوغان
رغبته بلقاء بشار الاسد والتعاون معه حتى
وصلت الاوضاع حد تشكيل اللجنه مشتركه
للتطبيع واعاده اللاجئين الى المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه
شكل القوميون حجر الزاويه في تحالفات
اردوغان الداخليه والانتخابيه
فالتحالف مع حزب الحركه القوميه مكن الرجل
من حسم التحول الى النظام الرئاسي عام
والانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2018
تحالفات اختتمها اردوغان مع القومي
المتشدد سنان اوغان للفوز بالانتخابات
الاخيره
اردوغان الفائز اليوم وان احتفظ بخطابه
الديني الثقافي اليوم الا انه لم يعد بحسب
الكثيرين اردوغان الاسلامي بل اردوغان
القومي اتى تركيا رغما عن الاتاتوركين
بعيدا عن خطاب مطلع الالفي والتغيير لكن
دائما امبرغماتيا فالواقع يقول
اردوغان اليوم غير اردوغان الامس
الانتخابات التي شغلت تركيا والعالم حسمت
بتمديد عباءه الحكم للرئيس اردوغان لولايه
ثالثه وحتى عام 2028 وهي الاخيره له طبعا
بموجب الدستور التركي الذي يمنعه من
الترشح لولايه رابعه بالارقام مشاهدينا
نتعرف على نسبه مشاركه الناخبين الاتراك
في جوله الاعاده والتي بلغت نحو 84% فيما
كانت الجوله الاولى كما نشاهد هنا 89
بالمئه ومن هنا لابد ان نتوقف عند الارقام
التي نالها اردوغان في ابرز المدن وغير
شيئا منها بدايه فلنتوقف عند المحافظه
التي خسرها اردوغان في الجوله الاولى وعاد
وقلص الفارق فيها في الجوله الثانيه اتحدث
هنا عن هاتاي وهي ابرز المناطق المتضرره
في الزلزال حيث في الجوله الثانيه بلغت
نسبه التصويت 49.
بالمئه اما في الجوله الاولى فبلغت
48.3% اي تقدم بفارق حوالي 12 الف صوت عن
جوله الاقتراع الاولى اما مشاهدينا في
المدن الكبرى مثل اسطنبول التي وصفت بانها
ام المعارك الانتخابيه فتقدم اردوغان
بالجوله الثانيه عن الجوله الاولى كما
نشاهد هنا بالجوله الثانيه 48 فصل 22%
بالجوله الاولى
46.68
اي قلص الفارق باكثر من 20 الف صوت مع
منافسهم ننتقل الى العاصمه التركيه انقره
وثاني اكبر المدن التركيه ايضا قلص فيها
هنا اردوغان الفارق مع منافسه كريستار
اوغلو بعد ما نال
48.77% في الجوله الثانيه وفي الجوله
الاولى
46% اي فارق اكثر من 100 الف صوت
وهذا يعني مزيد من الاصوات التي ساهمت
بفوز اردوغان في جوله الاعاده للانتخابات
التركيه
[موسيقى]
الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو زيدان سابدا بموضوع المعارضه
طبعا كل العين على المعارضه ما الذي سيحصل
بعد نتائج الانتخابات خصوصا وان هناك يعني
الكثير من علامات الاستفهام حول الحزب حزب
كيتشدار اوغلو ماذا سيحصل فيه هل سيكون
هناك انقسامات داخليه وغيره من الاسئله
لا شك ان المعارضه التركيه وبعد هذه
الهزيمه كان هناك اجتماع في مقر حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الليله الماضيه هنا في العاصمه
التركيه انقره بقياده زعيم المعارضه وزعيم
الحزب كمالكيجار بحسب ما ذكرته بعض وسائل
الاعلام ان بعض قيادات حزب الشعب الجمهوري
تقدمت بطلب استقاله لكلجدار اوغلو بعد
فشلها في اداء مهامها في الحملات الدعائيه
لكنها زعيم الحزب ورئيس الحزبده رفض هذه
الاستقاله وقال ان هناك استعدادات يجب ان
تبدا الاستعدادات الانتخابات البلديه في
اسرع وقت لكن يعني حتى الان هناك بعض
الاصوات المعارضه وبعض الصحفيين المعارضين
يطالبون سواء كان
كمال كل او ميرال اكشنر بالاستقاله بعد
الهزيمه امام الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لا شك ان السهام ستنصب بشكل كبير
على زعيم المع لعده اسباب اولا اسباب
الاساسي واصرار كمال كلجدار على الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه واذكر هنا في يوم
السادس من مارس الماضي ايضا على شاشه
العربيه عندما اعلن قرار التحالف الطاوله
السداسيه
قلت في النشرات المسائيه اذكر هذه الكلمه
هذه الجمله جيدا ان كلجدار اوغلو هو
المرشح المفضل للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لماذا لان كل استطلاعات الراي في
الشارع وحتى هذا الموضوع ايضا كان على
جنده الطاوله السداسيه ترشح او تعطي اكرم
امام اوغلو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ومنصور
يافاش رئيس بلديه انقره افضليه في التنافس
مع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكثر من
كمالك الجدولو يعني اليوم النسبه التي
امامنا اليوم اكثر من 47 تقترب من 48%
تقريبا هذه النسبه لم تتقدم نسبه المعارضه
في كل الانتخابات الماضيه لكن مع فرق
التكتيك يعني في 2014
البلاد شهدت اول انتخابات رئاسيه بشكل
مباشر لاختراع لرئيس الجمهوريه بشكل مباشر
مجموع كل الاصوات المرشحين مرشحين الذين
كانوا يمثلون احزاب المعارضه الذين
تنافسوا ضد اردوغان حصلوا على 48% بينما
حصل اردوغان على
52% او واحد او 51% تقريبا في انتخابات
2018 ايضا كان هناك اربع او خمس مرشحين
للمعارضه حصلوا جميعا على 47% اليوم نفس
النتيجه تتكرر لان الاصوات المعارضه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لم تتقدم او لم يكن
هناك زياده رغم ان اليوم اردوغان دخل هذه
الانتخابات في اسوا وضع يمكن ان يدخل به
رئيس جمهوريه هذه الانتخابات البلاد تعاني
من ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره وتضخم غير مسبوق
وازمه الزلزال لكن المعارضه لم تستغل هذه
الفرصه نعم
والاسابيع المقبله كيف ستكون الصوره من
هناك شكرا لك زيدان زين كل
و مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره بعد قليل
بعد ايام من الشبكات تسببت بوقوع قتلى
هدوء على الحدود الايرانيه الافغانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اتفاق سقف الدين
الامريكي في طريقه بعدما اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي ورئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري كيفن
مكارسي عن الاتفاق الذي ابرم بين الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي بشان رفع سقف الدين
والذي يتوجب اقراره قبل نفاذ اموال
الحكومه وشكل هذا الاتفاق بعد اسابيع من
المفاوضات مخرجا للطرفين للتراجع طبعا عن
حافه الهاويه
غضب جمهوري بوجه اتفاق سقف الدين الامريكي
بعدما اعلن العديد من الجمهوريين في
الكونجرس الرفض التام لتسويه بايدن مكارسي
وصولا الى عدم التصويت عليها في الخامس من
يونيو المقبل السنه
حذر منها بعدما شكك باحكام الصفقه
المتعلقه بالانفاق الدفاعي مقارنه مع
معدلات التضخم في الولايات المتحده مشددا
على ان الصفقه تردد صدى كارثه العزل عام
2011 مما يهدد الامن القومي للبلاد اما
النائب الجمهوري راراف نورمان فاعتبر بان
هذه الصفقه ضرب من الجنون لان زياده سقف
الدين بقيمه اربعه تريليونات دولار ستؤدي
الى الافلاس التام وبالتالي لن يصوت عليها
بدوره النائب دان بيشوب بان الولايات
المتحده سيكون لديها 35 تريليون دولار من
الديون في عام 2025 وهذا الامر غير مقبول
على الاطلاق ومن بين الاحكام الوارده في
الصفقه المبدئيه بقاء الانفاق غير الدفاعي
ثابت الى حد كبير خلال السنوات المقبله
ولن يرتفع في عام 2024 ويزيد بنسبه 1% فقط
عام 2025 ولتمرير الاتفاق مشاهدينا يجب ان
يصوت عليه مجلسي الكونجرس قبل الموعد
النهائي في الخامس من يونيو وبعد ذلك طبعا
ستتخلف الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
لاول مره في تاريخها وتلا هذا الاتفاق
ردود فعل ايجابيه على العقود الاجله في
اسواق ولصت والاسواق العالميه
[موسيقى]
من الولايات المتحده الى جارتها كندا حيث
اعلنت مدينه شرقيه البلاد حاله طوارئ
بعدما تسببت حرائق الغابات في عمليات
اجلاء واسعه وانقطاع تيار الكهربائي وقالت
سلطات انهم يعملون على مدار الساعه
للاستجابه لحالات الطوارئ للحفاظ على
سلامه الناس وتقليل التهديدات التي تشكلها
الحراق
الى كندا مشاهدينا حيث تنضم الينا رفاها
السعد مراسله العربيه رفاها كيف هي الصوره
من هناك ويعني هل تمكنت السلطات من
السيطره الجزئيه على هذه الحرائق
نعم لغايه الان وحسب اخر الاخبار ان
الحرائق غير مسيطره عليها نهائيا حيث تشير
المؤتمر الصحفي الاخير قبل قليل كان لنائب
رئيس لجنه الطوارئ الاقليميه قال لا تزال
الحرائق غير مسيطره عليها هناك
788 فدانا التهمتها
النيران تم اخلاء تقريبا عشر مناطق في
مدينه وما حولها اغلقت احد عشر مدرسه
الاحصائيات الاخيره تشير الى اجلاء 17,000
شخص تم نقلهم الى مناطق مختلفه تم فتح
ملعب كندا
المركزي في سوماس رضا الجريف
وتم اجراء الناجين في هذا المركز وايضا
فتحت بعض الفنادق امام اللاجئين الذين تم
اجلائهم
السلطات لن تسمح للناجين وقالت ان هذا
الاجلاء الزامي وغير مسموح لاي شخص في
العوده لغايه ان تبلغهم السلط طبعا مثل ما
تعلمين ان الحكومه الاقليميه اعلنت حاله
الطوارئ في هلي فاكس ماذا تعني حاله
الطوارئ في هذه الحالات بعد ان تم الانذار
الخامس لان كان هناك انذار الاول والانذار
الثاني ومن ثم الثالث الثالث واخره الخامس
الذي تم خلاله اعلان حاله الطوارئ حاله
الطوارئ تعني استخدام الاموال المخصصه
للطوارئ لان ما حدث غير مسبوق في في
مقاطعه نابلسي وايضا تحشيد المنظمات
والشركات وعدد من المدن الاخرى في مساعدات
وتقديم الدعم والعون رئيس الوزراء الكندي
جاستن ترودو اعلن خلال تغريد له على تويتر
قال ان الامر خطير هو غير مسبوق ايضا تحدث
نائب نائب رئيس لجنه الطوارئ تحدث عن
الاضرار قال ان هناك اخبار جيده واخبار
غير جيده الاخبار الجيده هي لم يكن هناك
اي ضحايا او مصابين او مفقودين اما
الاخبار الغير جيده فقال هناك دمار كبير
ودمار ش لان الرياح كانت بسرعه 60 كم في
الساعه هناك عشر مباني دمرت بالكامل لا
توجد ارقام معينه حتى الان بالنسبه
للمنازل التي تقدمت او حرقت هناك عدد كبير
من المركبات احرقت بالكامل الاجلاء مستمر
اما بالنسبه لرجال الاطفال فتم استدعاء
عدد من رجال الاطفال من كافه المدن
القريبه من اهاليفات قدر عددهم بمئه رجل
اطفاء طائرتين هليكوبتر تساعد في اخماد
هذه الحرائق ايضا شكرا لك رفاء سعد
مراسلات العربيه حدثنا من كندا
[موسيقى]
الى ايران حيث قال وزيره داخليه الايراني
احمد وحيد بان الحدود مع افغانستان مفتوحه
ولا توجد مشكله في حركه العبور اضف وحيده
لوكاله تسنيم الايرانيه للانباء بان
الاشتباكات الحدوديه بين ايران وافغانستان
كانت محدوده وتم حل هذه الاشتباكات تشددا
على ان الاوضاع على الحدود مع افغانستان
هادئه
[موسيقى]
قدره البشر على رؤيه الكون في السماء
الليل قد تختفي في غضون 20 عاما بسبب
التلوث الضوئي تحذير اطلقه علماء فلك
مقترحين تغيير الوان الاضاءه حول العالم
مشرين الى ان غياب بعض الالوان من الاضاءه
قد يكون سببا لمشاكل صحيه وقال موقع
علماء بان السنوات القليله الماضيه تفاقمت
فيها قضيه التلوث الضوئي بسرعه وذكر
العلماء بان التلوث الضوئي يضيء السماء في
الليل بمعادله تزايد بحوالي 10% سنويا
ويقول الموقع بان الطفل الذي يولد في مكان
يمكن فيه رؤيه 250 نجما حاليا سيكون قادرا
على رؤيه 100 نجم فقط بحلول الوقت الذي
يبلغ فيه سن 18 عاما
في ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا تذكير بابرز
العلم
اختطاف مواطن سعوديه على طريق مطار بيروت
وزير الداخليه اللبنانيه يحذر من العواقب
على علاقات لبنان العربيه ويتوعد خاطفيه
بعقاب القاسم
على وقعي تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
انتهاء هدنه الاسبوع الواحد في السودان
ومفاوضات جدا للضغط باتجاه التمديد
[موسيقى]
سمع اكياف تشهد اعنف معركه بين باتريوت
الغرب وصواريخ ومسيرات روسيا واوكرانيا
تتحدث عن منطقه منزوعه السلاح كشطن السلام
حرائق ضخمه وغير مسبوقه تفتك بكندا وسلطات
تعلن حاله الطوارئ في مناطق متضرره
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
الزميل طاهر مساء الخير طاهر مساء الخير
ليال نحن سنتابع
الهدنه في السودان بعد تمديدها قبل قليل
قضيه اختطاف المواطن السعودي في لبنان
وكذلك نتائج الانتخابات التركيه الهواء لك
طاهر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات